the film's entirely based on fact and
polarity roses it was a lot of research
with van drivers and with care workers I
mean it's a it's a family where both
parents are working an insecure work no
guaranteed income mum's on the zeros
contract dad's cycle self-employed and
their work long hours 12 hours or so a
day each they can do no holiday pay no
sick day and that inability to be with
your kids to see him grow up brings huge
stresses in the family so that's what in
suggests was the connection between the
world outside where we more or less keep
her you know keep putting on a smiley
face and the world inside of our
personal relationships where this you
drop you know you exhausted you drop the
smile and that's when the tensions the
stress the anger plays out so is that
the reality of the government's
austerity measures is that they often
unreported reality and well it's the
reality of the free market which the
government does everything to support
where harsh competition means that big
companies compete on price they cut
their labor costs by no holiday pay no
sick pay with workers they have no
responsibility to they can just sack
them overnight if something goes wrong
it's the responsibility of the driver he
gets into debt very quickly it's the
product of that free markets which we
told equal freedom because it doesn't it
equals it equals absolute exploitation
but the government supports it keeps it
in place keeps the the taxes on big
business low and keeps people in poverty
wages and a benefit system secure secure
system we designed to trap people in a
bureaucratic tangle so that they are so
terrified of being
of having to go to a food bank that they
will take any job however crude the
exploitation I want to ask you about
what you think cinema is what is cinema
for you obviously Martin Scorsese's
recently said that the the the Marvel
superhero movies are not cinema Francis
Ford Coppola has agreed with him saying
that they are despicable your films are
sort of the antithesis of superhero
films team
well films can be as it should be as
broad as the library you know it should
have everything should every kind of
story and situation we can imagine but
there's funny weather it's sad but
there's tragedy
whether it's comedy where this
documentary whether it takes us to form
different places whether it reflects the
world we know it should be everything
and I think reflecting the world we know
I can make beautiful cinema because it
can celebrate who we are it can laugh
with us they can cry with a second it
can learn about our deepest feelings and
what is to be human and that you find
that in every in the everyday and the
people who walk past you in the street
who the people who come to the house so
they see the superhero movies the
superhero movies I just find boring and
they're they're made as commodities this
is the essential point I think they're
made as commodities like you know
hamburgers or whatever and it's it's not
about communicating it's not about
sharing our imagination it's about it's
about makeup commodity that will make
profit for a big corporation they're
cynical they're cynical exercise will
the market exercise and it has nothing
to do with with with the art of cinema
William Blake you said when when any
form of monies and when money is
discussed art is impossible